hey guys we're here at CES unveiled at
scope tayos booth a French 3d printer
company that lets anyone print their own
3d designs using a cloud-based 3d
modeling system basically you you send
your file into sculpt a hose company and
you can print out anything from this
skull here to your your profile of your
face taken with your iPad or your iPhone
now the cost is a little bit up there
it's around three hundred dollars for
something a medium sized but it's
basically a way to bypass mass
manufactured objects and print your own
3d models of prototypes that you've
engineered it's pretty cool and it's
available now online at scope deo calm